[Music]
spirit is in it's simple truth
consciousness and forces its moments
apart action divides it into substance
and consciousness of the substance and
divides the substance as well as
consciousness substance as the universal
essence and n stands over against the
individualized reality the infinite
middle term is self-consciousness which
being the implicit unity of itself and
substance now becomes that unity
explicitly and unites the universal
essence and it's individualized reality
the latter it raises to the former act
ethically the former it brings down to
the latter and realizes the end the
substance which had an existence only in
thought it brings into existence the
unity of itself and substance as its own
work and thus as an actual existence
we're now at paragraph 444 and we've
reached the beginning of a subsection of
this massive spirit section and we'll
talk about that subsection a moment you
notice that we have two paragraphs 444
445 and then we're diving immediately
into the ethical world human and divine
law all these very interesting things so
this is some preliminary material Hegel
has already given us an introduction to
the spirit section as a totality now you
want to focus in and when I say focus
this is very relative because it's still
an awful lot of material that we're
looking at but he wants to focus in more
specifically on what is happening in
this first section in the first section
as you can see you know here it's titled
true spirit vara Geist the ethical order
and ethical order is translating vit
leak-tight you might translate that as
you know ethics or or there's a number
of other ways to translate it and Hegel
is going to be playing off I should
point out here between this leaf kite
and adjectives it leek and morality pet
in ways that if you have you know had an
introduction to ethics class or
something like that where where the
person was rigidly distinguishing
between morality which is how we're
translating morality test and did
leak-tight or you know these vika
ethics right if you've had somebody who
made very rigid distinctions that may
not correspond to the way Hegel himself
is distinguishing between these in a
certain respect you could say that vit
leaf kite is something that is more
basic and it's also a starting point
morality that morality is going to be
discussed
after spirit is in what we call an
estranged your alienated condition so
you want to keep that in the back of
your mind
not really that important at this point
but but is important as we're going
forward so the ethical order what does
the ethical order actually look like now
he doesn't tell us of course in this
paragraph because that is going to be
the subject for a dialectical exposition
which he's soon going to go into in just
two more paragraphs but he is telling us
about a dynamic that we want to keep in
mind so what is that dynamic what is he
charting out in this this paragraph
Hegel says spirit is in its simple truth
consciousness this is the key idea
what's what's determinative about
consciousness as we've seen by going
through the phenomenology and all these
different stages or shapes of
consciousness before this consciousness
is always differentiating itself as part
of the very nature of consciousness and
also synthesizing things at the same
time comparing them with each other and
we are dealing explicitly not just with
consciousness of an object but with self
consciousness because consciousness is
also aware of its own involvement in the
process its own position taking here
Hegel is going to talk about action or
we could say comportment if you like
hans lung if we want to distinguish
action as pop you know for other words
from Han bong I think this isn't you
know something that we have to insist on
too much but this is a action that is
oriented towards achieving something as
we're going to see so he goes on he says
action divides it what it spirit into
substance and consciousness of that Club
stuff so we've got substance
consciousness of the substance it looks
like Hegel said and in just a few
paragraphs earlier like we are retracing
the steps that were taken in the earlier
- Dalton right particularly in
cent certainty perception and the force
in the understanding however notice that
here we're focused on action on the
practical on the sphere of doing we
might say so he says it divides the
substance as well in as consciousness
right so the substance is going to be
divided into two main moments and we'll
talk about that in a moment notice what
else you saying there it divides it as
well as consciousness now consciousness
is divided in the sense that it is
consciousness of the substance but it is
also consciousness of itself and those
are not the same thing and yet they are
the same consciousness all right
so there is a division already going on
there here on the side of substance it's
divided into Universal essence and end
and individualized reality the word that
Hegel uses there for individualized
reality and I think it's a great
translation this you know individualized
is for I'm Zoltan so it's it's a I don't
want to read too much into the word
choice here but it but it's not just you
know an individual it's something that
has been individuated something has has
happened to it what's happened to it
well you know that the dialectics that
we've been looking at before and the
dialectics that are to come much of
which involve being in situations where
you have to make choices and you're
suffering and and not everybody sees it
the way that you see it and you are sort
of separated out from the ethical
substance that you thought you are a
part of through your action so these are
two sides and what connects those two
sides of the substance the ethical
substance with each other
Hegel goes on and he tells us he says
here we go substance as the universal
essence an end
and over against the individualized
reality the infinite middle term is
self-consciousness which being the
implicit unity of itself in substance
now becomes that unity explicitly and
unites the in the universal essence and
it's individualized reality so we have
we have something going on with
self-consciousness all the time anyway
involved in any action that we're taking
and now in these moments of what we
might call clarity and crisis where you
really do have to take a stand and you
really do have to try to at least think
through and explain not just to yourself
but to others what the hell are you
doing like for example you know you know
Hegel is going to later on consider this
famous case of Antigone having to say I
need to bury my brother even though he's
considered a traitor to my city because
the god require this of me and the gods
law is more important than the human law
in this case there is a process there
where what was originally just implicit
a conflict that was implicit comes to
the light and individuals have to sort
out where they actually fit in it's also
worth remembering that you've ever read
the Antigone that it's not just Antigone
who's trying to find her way it's just
as much crayon the ruler who has to
figure out where he fits in to this this
schema as well so self-consciousness
like he says becomes the mediating term
in this case so how does this take place
Hegel tells us the latter what's the
latter the individualized reality it
raises to the former that is the
universal essence and end and acts
ethically it makes some sort of
commitment or choice it behaves in a way
that is supposed to realize an end on
the other hand the end as we've seen so
often played out before is as a
universal just an ideal it has to be
realized in some
that actually has reality very excite
and that is the individual and his or
her action so he says the former it
brings down to the ladder and realizes
the end the substance which had an
existence only in thought it brings into
existence the unity of itself and
substance as its own work here
translating VX is something that is
produced right and thus as an actual
existence so what is happening here self
consciousness which we have seen you
know discussed in the self consciousness
section quite a bit in the reason
section now is taking on yet more
concreteness in relation to the ethical
substance which it is the mediating term
for you could think of this as self
consciousness is trying to figure out
where exactly it fits in and what it
ought to be doing in terms of what it
knows about not just the world as
objects but the world as other subjects
the world to which it belongs as a
community so how is this going to play
itself out this is all very abstract now
Hegel is going to make it a bit more
concrete but first we have to get
through the rest of this introductory
material
in this separation of the moments of
consciousness the simple substance has
on the one hand preserved the antithesis
to self-consciousness
and on the other it equally exhibits in
its own self the nature of consciousness
that is to create distinctions within
itself exhibiting itself as a world
articulated into its separate spheres it
does splits itself up into distinct
ethical substances into a human and a
divine law
similarly the self-consciousness
confronting the substance assigns to
itself according to its nature one of
these powers and as a knowing is on the
one hand ignorant of what it does and on
the other knows what it does a knowledge
which for that reason is a deceptive
knowledge it learns through its own act
the contradiction of those powers into
which the substance divided itself and
their mutual downfall as well as the
contradiction between its knowledge of
the ethical character of its action and
what is in its own proper nature ethical
and thus found finds its own downfall in
point of fact however the ethical
substance have developed through this
process into actual self consciousness
in other words this particular self has
become the actuality of what it is in
essence but precisely in this
development the ethical order has been
destroyed
hundred fifty-five concludes this very
short preliminary portion of the first
subsection of the massive spirit portion
of the phenomenology of spirit and it
seems like we're getting off to a really
good start however you might be a little
bit dismayed at the very end of the
paragraph where we discover that the
ethical order has been destroyed because
the ethical order is what this section
is all about right but this is where
we're going with it and Hegel is trying
to give us sort of the summary of the
process of development for
consciousnesses in their action and
their experience that that's being
charted out in this section so he's not
start giving us a set of principles or
anything like that but then we're going
to you know apply instead he's saying
look here's the road map and by the end
of this section expect that what we
thought we we could take for granted
this this ethical order you know the
ethical substance is sort of working out
for us and harmonious and everybody has
their place is all messed up so how do
we get there he says in the separation
of the moments of consciousness we just
talked about this in the past paragraph
these these moments of consciousness
separate themselves out the simple
substance has he says on the one hand
preserved the antithesis to
self-consciousness on the other hand it
equally exhibits in its own self the
nature of consciousness so this is a
very interesting point we're going to
pause right here what we've got going on
is that the simple and I put in
parentheses here ethical substance
because that's what we're talking about
right because it's done it is preserved
its antithesis is how it's being
translated here or if you like
contradiction or contrast Gagan Zacks
right this is fundamental notion that
drives the dialectic its preserved its
its opposition to self consciousness so
it's not what self consciousness is
but on the other hand it does have the
nature of consciousness because this
entire thing that we're talking about
here is consciousness so what is
consciousness do it tends to split
itself up or to divide itself out
separate itself into different moments
that are related to each other here what
are the moments he says it exhibits in
its own self the nature of self
consciousness creating distinctions
within itself exhibiting itself as a
world articulated into its separate
spheres ok so we've got the the ethical
world the the community the culture
whatever it is however we want to
conceptualize what ethical substance is
here and it separates itself out into
different spheres what is one of the
most basic spheres not necessarily
within our advanced technological
culture of today although you know
perhaps we can still find something like
this but within most societies as we
find them in time and certainly within
human literature a distinction into the
divine the sacred and the distinctively
human the profane right or if you like
the sacred and the secular and here
Hegel is talking about the divine law
and the human law why is he talking
about Locke because we're talking about
action here and not just action like
flying a kite or you know chewing gum or
something like that but ethical action
the things that we ought to do and laws
are in part how we conceptualize is we
this is not something that we have to
explain a great great length because
we've discussed this at you know
considerable depth and detail and all
these twists and turns in the previous
sections of the phenomenology but have
to work right so he goes on and he says
a divine and a human law now here's
where it gets really interesting
similarly the self-consciousness
confronting the substance assigns to
itself according to its nature one of
these powers
so these are you know next these are you
know powers these are things that exist
out in the social world and that can
compel in some sense now of course we
notice that the law compels in a very
different way than a physical law does
you know
drop the book gravity just pulls it down
right whereas we can break these sorts
of laws but there are consequences and
there is an enforcement mechanism you
might say or sometimes you find out that
there isn't an enforcement mechanism and
it was just us enforcing it upon
ourselves but be that as it may
self-consciousness sides with one or the
other of these now does it do this all
the time is this something that
self-consciousness
is continually mulling over in its head
no no no this is only when we find that
there is something that compels us to
think about this or if we are the sort
of people who really do enjoy thinking
and then perhaps you could say that
enjoyment that desire draws us into
thinking about this and then that can
actually provoke crises for other people
if we say what we've been thinking about
right when they do find themselves in
situations as human self-consciousness
is rational self consciousnesses where
they have to side with one or the other
they have to you know you can't sit on
the fence forever you have to pick one
of these will it be the human law the
human law has a lot going for it right
that tends to be the day to day a way of
understanding things that we can easily
relate to and even though it may have
some you know problems within itself or
some hidden contradictions that will
come to light we can certainly say AHA
this is something that I not only i but
everybody else around me agrees with
when you're the one who's standing up
for divine
you often find yourself in a rather
lonely position and yet at the same time
this does come in as a live possibility
as a I do have to take a stand here we
might think of Hegel's favorite example
which is that event Icahn E and we might
think of another one of his favorite
examples you know which he discusses for
example in the history the philosophy of
history which is Martin Luther you know
I have to take a stand here so we have
to choose one or the other at some point
the language here is very interesting so
Miller has this translated as
self-consciousness assigns to itself
according to its nature one of these
powers now its nature here is Bazin so
that makes some sense but essence could
have also have been translated that way
but you could think of this as an
essence that you are actually choosing
in some respect but also not choosing
you you select that one because you find
it compelling you find it it has a
greater claim than the other one so you
know we might think of Creon saying wait
a second I've got to run a city here
why is Korean backing up the the human
law and doubling down on it because he
sees some validity to it and it's it's
not just a matter of temperament that
crayon is just a jerk or something like
that no there's a real issue here that's
why Greek tragedy is so wonderful
because it's got these characters from
very determined places and times that
have sort of a universal significance
and Hegel is calling out some of that
Universal significance here the language
of again Miller has assigns to itself
you could also say select and you could
say sides with assigns itself works
because it's tightly you know
chooses a portion for itself and it's
not just here's where it gets really
interesting so the law or the simple
ethical substance has been split down
into two main things and you pick which
one you want sort of like saying all
right
you know it's dinner time is it going to
be meatloaf or chicken sandwich you
don't get you can't have both
one or the other well I will select the
meatloaf I'm taking something out of the
range of possibilities for myself
similarly you know are you going to
support the war are you going to be
against the war are you going to hide
your head are you going to sort of sit
on the fence okay there's four
possibilities you pick one of those
possibilities and you lose the rest
right so that's a you know Thailand that
is a taking a part in tile but you're
also choosing yourself you're choosing
where you're going to place yourself
you're assigning yourself you're
assigning one of these to yourself but
you're also assigning yourself to one of
these the divine law or the human law
now Hegel says something really quite
interesting here that we'll see makes
more sense as we go through this section
and it's paragraphs he says it as a
knowing it is on the one hand ignorant
of what it does and on the other knows
what it does so there's a bifurcation in
self-consciousness itself in terms of
its knowing it's you know grasping what
is happening to itself and in terms of
these ethical possibilities and its
commitments and it somewhat knows what
it's doing but it also doesn't know what
it's doing which means that if knowledge
is as Hegel will say here a deceptive
knowledge and you might say if you're
really a stickler well that's no kind of
knowledge whatsoever Hegel doesn't say
that so I'm not going to tell you why he
doesn't say
at at this point but let's keep that in
the back of our heads as we move through
this section now the rest of what he has
to say I didn't actually put on the
board but we can see where it fits in
with us
so he says because of this it's learning
through its own act the contradiction of
those powers into which the substance
divided itself and their mutual downfall
both of these are going to be revealed
as fundamentally problematic which means
that its commitment to one or the other
of these is also revealed as
fundamentally problematic now the term
contradictory that he uses your
contradiction is vitas Brooke which is a
different turn than Gagan sucks I mean
they both are kind of similar right and
they both have the element of being
against gag inner theater and then
they're both coming from language
language about language right Zach right
and Brooke these are both coming from
you know the stems for saying for
talking for for indicating but you
doesn't use the same term right here we
have a contradiction that is that is
arising a contradiction of these powers
a contradiction between its knowledge of
the ethical character of its action and
what is it is in its own proper nature
ethical there's a second contradiction
arising right
and thus finds its own downfall it finds
that it cannot sustain the I don't want
to say account because that makes it
sound as if it's sort of distanced from
this and it's looking at it in a purely
speculative manner the person in siding
with one or the other of these is
assuming that there is a solution to the
puzzle of what is ethical what ought I
to do
what would be the best thing
for me to do in a bad situation and as
it turns out when it when it learns
about this through its own experience
and thinking about it it is unable to
sustain any true account that really
does make sense of this this is a
fundamental problem this is also an
achievement this is not lapsing into
sort of a moral skepticism or relativism
let alone and nihilism it's a step
forward to see where the you know Gagan
Zetas and the leadership book lies
within our ethical experience our
ethical commitments indeed are our
entire relationship with something
bigger than ourselves that Hagel here is
calling ethical substance so he goes on
and he says in point of fact the ethical
substance has developed through this
process into actual self consciousness
this is a necessary step
this particular self has become the
actuality of what it is in essence but
precisely in this development the
ethical order has been destroyed so the
ethical order has been destroyed then
the question is great where then do we
find what we actually need in order to
be ethical and the answer is going to be
a set of other proposals that we can
historically identify with actual
projects that were put forward not just
as philosophers theories but as live you
know options that people were pursuing
institutionally through history and
Hegel is taking a long view on this now
all of that is yet to come
so you'll see this developing as we move
through the paragraphs but now we have
some sense about where we're going